♪♪
Detective Danner:
This... is a murder.
Ahhh!
Whaaat?
♪♪
Xavier:
Hey hey!
Party people!
Xavier:
Big ups to Hillmount High.
We started at the upper middle,
and now we here.
But for tonight, mi casa...
is...
well, I mean, you know how the
rest of that goes!
Xavier:
Whoa!
We gonna live forever!
♪♪
(Screaming)
How did this all go so wrong?
♪♪
Reporter:
Popstar, actor and celebrity
humanitarian, Xavier, was found dead tonight.
Reporter:
His body discovered on the cliff
during an afterparty for his high school reunion.
This is a murder.
Whaaat?
Any one of you could be the
murderer, and I want to hear
your story.
The same thing could happen, but
you see it in a different way.
Detective Danner:
I want to hear your mind movie.
♪♪
Jennifer:
Did you see her hair?
It looks like she made out with
a tornado.
Tornado.
It’s just Jewish hair.
So much volume.
My goal is to find out who
killed Xavier.
Detective Danner:
Now, you all went to your
high school reunion,
Detective Danner:
for what? Second chances?
At life? Love? Something else?
I would just love it if you
could just skip to the part
where the murder happens.
I’m telling you a story here!
I’m building character arcs,
dynamics.
(Lip smack)
Brett:
Everybody here hated Xavier.
He is the worst.
I'm gonna have sex with your ex.
Dude, 6 years old.
Daddy, I love him.
Everyone seems to think you did
it.
Everyone. It’s all anyone’s
talking about.
Haha.
Sorry, you’re you, that’s not
fun.
Any one of us could snap.
What? Who?
Whoa!
(Grunting)
Hahaha!
You want to confess to a murder,
'cause we need to know who
killed him tonight.
Bam!
Aniq:
Everybody seems to be hiding
something.
What is going on?!
♪♪
(Screaming)
God!
We’re done here.
Yeah, but you didn’t even know
that was fake and you straight
up just chopped off his head.
Remember that.